Dylan Mulvaney
the man who pretends to be a girl on
social media has gone corporate he's now
Shilling an ad for instacart note to
self never use instacart again and in
this advertisement for instacart I think
he accidentally shows you
what lies at the heart of basically all
of our modern political problems
on instacart that y'all can shop to get
my dream sleepover experience
[Music]
speaking of my order is here
I have the delivery first things first
skin care and I'm warning you beforehand
I eat mostly junk food but we're having
a sleepover so it's allowed
oh they're hot it's hot I still have
room in my dessert stomach so we're
having ice cream
I think we start with prank calls and
then put a finger down then we'll go
around and manifest all of our dreams
and goals for the rest of the year then
a rom-com and then we can paint our
nails and we're gonna stay up all night
long visit the link in my bio to shop
Dylan's sleepover Essentials via
instacart now
so everybody's focusing on one that this
guy's now got a corporate sponsorship
that's the that's one level of analysis
or they'll focus on this guy he's just
doing a caricature of of you know a sort
of 90s sitcom gay man or a ridiculous
cartoon of what men think women are like
and it's just that's so offensive and
he's wearing women's face and this is
okay that's another level of analysis
that's not what caught my attention one
word caught my attention in that video
manifest
did you hear that in between the popcorn
and the rom-com and it he said we're
going to manifest our futures together
we're going to manifest our Destinies
and then we're going to do
remember manifest or not manifest
destiny that would be pretty cool
actually we're going to manifest our
dreams and desires
that word manifest is the language of
New Age occultism
it's it's a very
weird kind of demonic idea that you can
make yourself into a sort of a God and
make demands on God himself and demands
on the entire universe and that it will
just happen this is what you see in that
book The Secret and in lots of kind of
weird new agey self-help Oprah kind of
stuff
is this idea that you're really a Divine
you're the Divine spirit and if you just
if you just believe enough in your own
power and the power of your your
Consciousness and your energy you can
make the universe do whatever you want
and it's it's a cult and it's demonic
and it made me realize oh you know what
all of this is about you know what all
of this is about it's not about the
second wave feminists and it's not about
the rise of this particular ideology or
this particular time it's not about you
know the the critical theory Department
of the you know it's you know what it's
about
it's it's because people aren't getting
baptized
so what I know I know Media Matters is
going to clip this out good I hope you
do clip this out because I want people
to hear this
why is all why is the world getting so
insane right now
I think once you get past all the layers
of the economic analysis and the
political ideological you know it's
because
public religion is on the decline people
are not getting baptized and so they're
not during baptism during traditional
right of baptism
three exorcisms are performed on the
person being baptized to cast out the
demons that prowl about the world
seeking the ruin of souls because this
is a very Fallen World and uh this is a
wonderful thing and then you get the
demons cast out of you and you don't
need to worry about this stuff as much
anymore well now people aren't being
baptized and the demons are just running
amok this stuff the Dylan Mulvaney stuff
the transgender stuff it's just demonic
think about furries have you heard of
furries you know furries are these
people who have this weird sexual fetish
where they think that they're basically
possessed by the spirits of animals
that's just Demons What do you call what
would you if you went back in a time
machine
500 years and you were talking to Ye
Olde Johnny Smith down the street
and you said oh hi there Mr Smith yeah
I'm from the future and I'm actually I'm
something called a furry he says what's
a furry lad and I don't know I don't
know why he's Irish and and you say oh
furry well you see I'm I am actually I
know I look like a human but I'm
actually the spirit of an animal and
that's really what animates me and so
I'm really a chipmunk and that's that's
my true Spirit he'd look at you probably
a little wacky and he'd say oh you're
possessed by a demon lady you know go
get down to the local priest and get
exercise these people
who say that not only are they one
gender but they're multiple genders in
their heads we've we've played this
these clips on the show of people who
say I've got these head mates these head
partners and they're all these different
personalities in my head so one day I'm
a boy one day I'm a girl one depending
on who's kind of in control of my buddy
what do you call that it's just demons
man it's just demons like I and I know
that people are going to look at me like
I'm crazy when I say that but what is
crazier
because for all of human history every
single place in the world including in
Christendom and every Pagan culture
everywhere forever
everyone has had some sense that there
is not only a physical world but a
spiritual world and that some Spirits
are good and some Spirits are bad and
the bad spirits are demons and they do
weird stuff to humanity okay everyone
for all of human history has thought
that until about five minutes ago in our
stupid atheist civilization and now our
explanation for these phenomena is that
actually boys can secretly be girls and
sometimes people actually are animated
by the spirits of chipmunks and that
actually if you believe enough in your
Consciousness and your energy you can
make the universe Bend toward your
specific will through manifesting
through the secret and the Oprah book
love and the some of the most popular
media out there which which is crazier
obviously the modern stuff is crazier
I know that it seems like really
simplistic political analysis to say
that the cure for these problems is to
just go and get baptized but that is if
people why did this stuff go away in the
Middle Ages in ancient Pagan cultures
you had you had furries okay in ancient
Pagan cultures you had something akin to
transgenderism and people just feeling
that they were possessed by all sorts of
spirits why did it largely go away
throughout Christendom
I know the atheists and the Liberals and
the rationalists are not going to
believe me it's because people were
baptized and because the demons were not
allowed to run amok but they are now and
that's very bad and we should strongly
discourage it okay Dylan Mulvaney he
definitely needs a psychologist but he
he more than that even he he really
needs a priest today is music Monday
baby and so my producers assure me
they've got a wonderful song for me to
listen to to analyze because I am a
hip-hop Maven the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]